Cele mai bune supercalculatoare clasice ale noastre devin tot mai puternice,
și ne pricepem din ce în ce mai bine la calcul, inclusiv la simularea sistemelor.
Dar simularea naturii e, în general, o problemă foarte dificilă.
Mă numesc Victoria Lipinska și azi vom explora unul dintre algoritmii
care ar putea face posibilă simularea naturii pe un calculator cuantic.
Să începem cu un exemplu și să luăm în considerare cafeina.
E o moleculă simplă.
Pentru a reprezenta configurația energetică a unei singure molecule de cafeină,
am avea nevoie de aproximativ zece la puterea 48 de biți.
Adică zece cu 48 de zerouri
și reprezintă aproximativ 10% din numărul de atomi din Pământ.
Și lucrurile se înrăutățesc, de fapt.
Dacă ai 125 de orbitali și vrei să stochezi toate configurațiile posibile,
ai nevoie de mai multă memorie
în calculatorul tău clasic decât există atomi în univers.
E imposibil de reprezentat cu supercalculatoare.
Există totuși speranță pentru calculatoarele cuantice,
deoarece sunt în mod intrinsec bune la simularea naturii.
Pentru o moleculă de cafeină, asta ar însemna reprezentarea
sistemului folosind 160 de qubits.
Sună mult mai ușor de gestionat.
Au fost propuși diverși algoritmi cuantici care permit
calculatoarelor cuantice mai mici să simuleze natura euristic.
Iată: variational quantum eigensolver sau VQE.
VQE e un algoritm care rulează parțial pe un calculator cuantic
și parțial pe un calculator clasic.
Ne permite să găsim valori care rezolvă o problemă de optimizare dată.
VQE e strâns legat de alte metode care implică
variația parametrilor, cum ar fi quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
Identificarea aplicațiilor VQE în industria ta sau în cercetare
este oarecum o artă, dar există niște linii directoare generale.
În general, VQE se aplică problemelor ce pot fi formulate
ca o problemă de optimizare cu variabile continue.
Acesta e cazul, de exemplu, în mare parte din chimia cuantică.
Foarte des, în chimie, ne interesează starea fundamentală.
Starea fundamentală este starea de energie minimă a sistemului.
Pentru a găsi energia stării fundamentale, VQE explorează
energia pentru diferite configurații ale sistemului
și caută configurația cu energia cea mai mică.
La un nivel înalt, VQE primește ca intrare o descriere a sistemului cuantic
și caută energia minimă.
Face asta variind configurația sistemului.
Pentru început, trebuie să introducem o descriere adecvată a sistemului
pe care calculatorul cuantic o înțelege și un set de parametri care îl descriu
și care vor fi optimizați.
Partea cuantică a
algoritmului pregătește sistemul într-o stare
descrisă de un set dat de parametri și calculează energia.
În timp ce partea clasică este responsabilă
de optimizarea acelor parametri la fiecare pas.
Acest proces cuantic-clasic se repetă
până ajungem la energia minimă.
Hai să facem acum zoom pe ce se întâmplă sub capotă.
Configurația energetică este descrisă de obicei prin Hamiltonianul
și de obicei e o matrice foarte mare.
În algebră, pentru a găsi cea mai mică valoare proprie a matricei
corespunzătoare energiei minime a sistemului,
am face pur și simplu descompunerea valorilor singulare.
Însă matricele pe care le vom analiza sunt exponențial de mari
și e o problemă exponențial de dificilă să faci asta algebric.
Acest Hamiltonian trebuie reprezentat în forma
pe care calculatorul cuantic o poate înțelege.
Deci tradus din limbajul chimiei în limbajul calculului cuantic.
Nu-ți face griji pentru detalii, însă.
În final, există metode programabile pentru a transforma Hamiltonianul, de obicei
cel din chimie, într-un Hamiltonian înțeles de un calculator cuantic.
Apoi introducem acest
Hamiltonian împreună cu circuit-ul, pe care îl numim formă variațională.
Alegerea unei forme variaționale este oarecum o artă.
Din nou,
reprezintă cea mai bună estimare a noastră privind starea cuantică a sistemului.
Acest circuit variațional este parametrizat cu un set de parametri theta,
și introducem, de asemenea, o alegere inițială a acestor parametri.
Pe baza acestora, partea cuantică a VQE:
pregătește starea de referință, de exemplu, starea zero;
folosește un circuit cuantic parametrizat, forma variațională, pentru a pregăti o stare cuantică
pentru o estimare inițială a parametrilor pe calculatorul cuantic; și estimează
energia corespunzătoare stării evaluate prin Hamiltonian.
Această estimare a energiei este apoi transmisă
optimizatorului clasic, care găsește un nou set de parametri.
Parametrii ajung din nou la solver-ul cuantic,
și întregul proces se repetă.
Calculatorul cuantic găsește o nouă estimare a energiei,
optimizatorul clasic găsește un nou set de parametri și tot așa.
Repetăm acest proces până când soluția converge.
Adică până când diferența dintre rezultatele de la pași consecutivi este suficient de mică
pentru nevoile noastre.
La final, algoritmul returnează acea energie minimizată.
Bine, asta e grozav.
Dar poate te întrebi cum știm că asta funcționează de fapt
și că nu vom găsi accidental o energie mai mică decât cea pe care o căutăm?
E o întrebare foarte bună.
Se dovedește că nu putem estima niciodată o energie mai mică.
Asta se datorează a ceva ce numim principiu variațional.
Principiul variațional spune că cea mai mare limită inferioară
a energiei sistemului este întotdeauna
energia sa minimă corespunzătoare stării fundamentale.
Asta înseamnă că energia evaluată pe orice altă stare a sistemului
va fi întotdeauna mai mare decât energia minimă.
Prin urmare, cu VQE nu putem obține niciodată ceva
mai mic decât energia stării fundamentale.
Totuși, putem converge la ceva
mai mare decât minimul pe care îl căutăm.
Asta se numește adesea o soluție metastabilă
și e o provocare pe care cercetătorii încearcă să o rezolve zilnic.
VQE e util deoarece folosește circuit-uri mai puțin adânci
față de alte protocoale care ne permit să estimăm energia stării fundamentale.
Asta îl face potrivit pentru hardware-ul cuantic de generație apropiată.
În acest video, am avut o privire de ansamblu asupra ce poate face VQE și cum e construit.
Dar te încurajez să explorezi Qiskit în acest context.
Chiar dacă suntem încă la începutul călătoriei noastre cuantice,
s-ar putea să îl găsești deja util pentru problemele pe care încerci să le rezolvi.
Mă numesc Victoria Lipinska și acesta a fost un rezumat
al algoritmului variational quantum eigensolver.